CBS Evening News anchor Jeff Glor spoke
with four members of a congregation that
worships at the Tree of Life synagogue
rabbi Doris Diane her husband Dean root
and their friends Seymour and Ruth
Drescher knew some of the victims three
of them say they avoided injury because
they were running late to services Jeff
you hear these details and it just
breaks your heart I'm struck by the
images this morning of the pictures that
we put up on the screen of the victims
here and also the jarring and clashing
images here outside the synagogue this
morning the beauty of the Stars of David
surrounded by as you said the FBI just
arriving
police tape lining the mobile command
unit bomb sniffing dogs it's
heartbreaking to think about we we spoke
to these four yesterday about what they
experienced Saturday morning there were
shards of glass all over the sidewalk
and at the same moment we heard the boom
boom boom boom and then Dean said it's
active gunfire run we ran to the car
dialed 9-1-1 if we had been there three
minutes earlier that may be 200 it
couldn't be talking to you we wouldn't
be here we wouldn't be talking to you we
process that I'm not sure I processed it
yet
no you saw them only because you were
arriving late and I see them waving and
saying don't go don't go and get out and
then somebody else came running out he
said there are guns shotguns going off
in time not having been there my
gratitude was very selfish I was very
very very grateful that he came home
you've drawn your curtains now at home
yes why sudden phobia required in the
moment
Dean I noticed just before the interview
started your you were holding your
wife's and you were also holding sighs
hand the way to respond
in a moment a lot of trauma is to reject
yeah
from each other
rabbi Doris told me she's not sure she
can ever go back inside this synagogue
again Veon I know it's something that a
lot of people a lot of folks here
wrestling with and also that and what
should be done with the shooter but more
immediately what what everyone's just
trying to do here is take care of their
friends yeah and many ask why were these
victims so many of them elderly and they
said elderly arrived on they arrived
actually earlier than services begin
we've already witnessed in the past some
of the worst of humanity and now are
once again thank you for bringing that
to us